we are right now watching clouds build
around the valley anticipating more rain
today this though was the scene about 24
hours ago reports of flooding in parts
of the valley check this out this is the
Las Vegas Motor Speedway look at that
River of water and always a reminder not
to drive through the flood water turn
around don't drown we thank you for
being here at noon Heather Mills joining
you and Sherry I'm in I'm in your space
here because welcome we got some stuff
going on you better put your waders on
because we got a lot of water already up
in the mountains oh okay so it is really
important that we pay attention to the
flood watch that was issued early this
morning by the National Weather Service
for a very good reason air is super
muggy and ripe for thunderstorms again
today this is the picture right now over
the spring mountains where thunderstorms
have been firing a little more than an
hour ago dropping some very heavy
rainfall 89 here in the valley
temperatures in the 60s up there we've
got dew points in the 60s a lot of humid
let's go straight to the radar because I
want to show you how these thunderstorms
have been exploding through the spring
mountains all of the elements coming
together moisture energy sunshine and a
lot of lift over the mountains there has
been one to two inches of rain estimated
that has fallen over the Northern end of
the spring mountains that's why the
National Weather Service and you can see
how the thunderstorms are really
starting to stretch out now along the
spine of the mountains all the way down
across state route 160 to mount potency
there is a flash flood warning that was
just issued a couple of minutes ago by
the National Weather Service for this
area that includes the small community
of Cold Creek which sits at about 4 800
feet it's going to get all the runoff a
lot of the runoff from that Heavy Rain
cell up on the North End of the
mountains if it's not already getting
some flooding it will very shortly that
lasts until three o'clock this afternoon
otherwise Las Vegas and western and
southern Clark County Southern night
County included in a flood watch for the
rest of the day into early tomorrow
we'll talk about our chances for
thunderstorms that could drop some heavy
flooding rains for the rest of your
Tuesday Heather that's coming up in your
most accurate weather now forecast all
right